Don Tom is not asking anymore he's not
being nice anymore telling General
Motors I asked you to start ramping up
and making more ventilators you've been
dragging your feet so now I am demanding
you to do so using some defense power is
that the chief executive of America has
that date back to the Korean War to make
that happen
but will it happen and is it a little
too little too late it's never too late
to Mark Cuban but it's a good move on
the part of the president he says he
joins us right now I'm talking about the
Dallas Mavericks owner and of course
multi billionaire Mark Cuban mark what
do you think of what the president's
doing here
forcing you know corporate America's
hand to help out much as President
Franklin Roosevelt did after the attack
on Pearl Harbor to rev up our military
machine what do you think long as he
gets the job done that's all that
matters there's obviously people's lives
on the line and so something has to
happen you know they were talking before
I don't know what went wrong but if it
gets general motor to general motors to
get the job done I'm all for it um you
were critical at 3m not so much that
they're ramping up production of the
ventilators and other things but but
more to the point that they weren't
doing enough on the face van side to
keep those prices down
maybe I'm getting that wrong can you
explain sure 3m first they get credit
for ramping up production absolutely but
they sell up until recently they sell as
best I can tell exclusively through
distribution meaning they if you go to
their website there's a list of
distributors that resell their n95 mat
now what's been happening is obviously
everybody's aware of the shortages in
the crisis just crisis around the n95
mask not being available for health care
workers and they apparently have just
let their distributors price whatever
they want to price the mask at and a lot
in a lot of cases they're not selling
them to health care providers those
distributors are selling them to
resellers and black marketers who are
then trying to jack up the price even
higher than the distributor's did and my
point was in all this there's a
contractual relationship between the 3m
licensed distributors and 3m corporate
it would have been very easy for them to
say very strongly that if you don't sell
if you don't take the inventory we're
providing you and sell directly to
hospitals and health care providers that
need the math when your contract comes
up we're going to end that contract but
that's not what they did and I have a
huge problem with that and what's
happening now is the the federal
government and I've tried to help as
much as I can
turning over some of these people who
say they have inventory and want to sell
it to me at a jacked up price the
federal government is starting to go
after some of the the middleman who have
gotten in the way and helped to make
this market really inefficient and
enable all the price gouging and my
feeling has been if the CEO of 3m said
don't do it this could have stopped a
long time ago if the CEO of 3m said I
only want you to stop do health care
providers this work stopped a long time
ago mark well I have you the president
yesterday when he addressed the American
people Adisa almost daily briefings he
and his task force of that said he told
his vice president not to call governors
who are not appreciative of his
coronavirus help that would include the
governors of Washington State and
Michigan with whom he's had an
acrimonious relationship I guess and
they would he now it didn't stop up him
from declaring that the disaster
assistance that Michigan wanted but what
do you think of that to corner or cite
those who were appreciative of his
efforts versus those who are not
I mean it's wrong obviously but the good
news is I think and I didn't you hate to
say this I think there's a lot of people
in government who were just ignoring
what he says on Twitter and ignoring
what he says in the briefing and doing
the right thing I mean you know
president's prompt is who he is we're
not going to change him but and I think
after three three years now people
underneath him in government and
different departments know that you know
if they just go about their job and do
the right thing it'll all work out so
well it's obviously you know not the
smartest thing to do by the president
the good news is at least at least with
people that I've dealt with even at
lowest levels they like just head down
doing the right thing doing their job
knowing that
you know helping to get ventilators
helping to get matched where they need
to be is the right thing to do
so if his words are not matching his
actions in a good way and then oh he
might be talking tough and angry at
those governors are not appreciative of
his efforts but he's not taking it out
on them in terms least in the case of
Michigan on aid or disaster relief that
the mission and governor said she wanted
and she got yeah I mean but well I say
it in the first place you know leaders
lead and I'll give Donald Trump ret
credit for things when he when he does
the right thing he's deferred to dr.
Falchi he's referred to his experts when
it comes to the coronavirus you know as
of recently um but come on you know in a
crisis like this this is not the time to
create animosity and increase the
people's stress and I recognize he's
still behind the scenes he's allowing
things to happen he would have the
opportunity to stop them if you wanted
to but yummy you know look let me add to
it I'll lead in this time of imperfect
information no matter what any leaders
do is going to be wrong at some level
but there's no reason to add to the
stress and it's unfortunate because it
takes away from the good things that he
is doing like what he's done with
General Motors like getting equipment
you know like enabling FEMA there's so
many things that have happened in this
crisis that have turned out to be
positive that his administration has
enabled but he diminishes all that with
all the you know ancillary commentary
and you just you know I don't think he's
ever gonna change
so it is what it is but it's unfortunate
well I still have your mark you know a
lot of people want to see an end game to
this the president was talking about
maybe sort of easing up on a lot of
restrictions and sheltering homes up as
soon as Eastern he's backed away from
that others said they simply don't know
what is a good time to start thinking
that way
have you given that much thought but
what do you think yeah I mean my thought
is I have one thought I'm not doing
anything with my employees until I know
they're absolutely safe you know I'm not
gonna ask them come to work I'm not
gonna ask them to leave their house all
this is uncertain nobody really has
answers and you know we're making
progress that's the good news you know
you're seeing from Abbott
the 15 to 45 minute test so that we can
quickly determine if someone has Tobit
that's a great step forward so I trust
science
I trust American ingenuity I trust ours
our ability to create new solutions and
therapies and when those experts when
dr. fouled she tells me it's okay to let
my employees leave the house that's when
I'll do it you know for all the reasons
we just mentioned earlier all the chit
chat that's going on all the discussions
in the press briefing you know that
that's really not relevant to the
decision-making process
Mark Cuban thank you very much my best
to you and your family sheltering those
kids and all that